son las imágenes de una ciudad preparada
para la batalla lo llevan haciendo desde
el 24 de febrero porque odessa la perla
del mar negro es una de las ciudades más
codiciadas por vladimir putin
ubicada en el sur del país es la salida
al mar negro de ucrania a 500 kilómetros
de kiev tiene un millón de habitantes y
es de mayoría rusófona está situada
junto a mykolaiv donde rusia avanza tras
haber conquistado gerson esta provincia
con linda con crimea anexionada por
rusia en 2014 si putin logra odessa
significará que ucrania se queda sin
salida al mar en uno de los puntos
estratégicos y comerciales más
importantes para kiev ya que es el
principal puerto del país además es
fronteriza con moldavia donde se ubica
la región separatista prorrusa de
transnistria allí existe despliegue de
tropas rusas igual que en el mar negro
sin embargo pese a estar rodeada o
dehesa no ha recibido ningún ataque
el retraso en el avance la voluntad de
rodear desde el este la ciudad y los
preparativos de defensa son algunos
motivos pero también que rusia quiere
tomarlas sin grandes daños
arquitectónicos
de ahí su importancia a nivel histórico
fundada en 1794 por catalina la grande
fue la joya del imperio ruso y para
vladimir putin es parte de la nueva
rusia que quiere construir y en relación
a esto pudiera dado gran importancia
tras los últimos eventos el 'viernes
negro' el 2 de mayo de 2014 cuando 48
pro rusos fueron masacrados en pleno
levantamiento de odessa coincidente con
el de las repúblicas del donbass aunque
de sant no llegó a entrar en guerra
posteriormente
conocida por su atractivo turístico sus
soleadas playas y su vida cosmopolita
que ahora se prepara para la que
consideran que puede ser la batalla
definitiva tras la invasión